>> TUCKER CARLSON: WELCOME.
TONIGHT, A SIGNIFICANT DAY IN
THE RECENT HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE'LL HAVE AN HOUR OF DETAILS
FOR YOU.
BUT BEFORE WE JUMP INTO THEM, A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT.
HERE'S HOW THE STORY STARTED
JUST SO WE ALL REMEMBER.
17-YEAR-OLD KYLE RITTENHOUSE
WOUND UP ON THE STREET IN
KENOSHA IN THE FIST PLACE WITH A
GUN FOR ONE REASON, HE WAS THERE
BECAUSE IN THE SUMMER OF 2020,
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ENDORSED MOB VIOLENCE FOR
POLITICAL ENDS.
THAT'S WHY THERE WERE RIOTS IN
KENOSHA THAT NIGHT, BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE KAMALA HARRIS
SUPPORTED THE RIOTS.
MORE THAN A YEAR LATER AS
RITTENHOUSE STOOD TRIAL FOR
MURDER, THE SAME PEOPLE IMPLIED
THERE WOULD BE MORE VIOLENCE IF
HE WAS ACQUITTED.
SO IMAGINE BEING A JUROR ON THAT
CASE.
IMAGINE THE PRESSURE AND THE
FEAR?
IT WOULD TAKE ENORMOUS MORAL
COURAGE FOR ANY JUROR TO IGNORE
THE THREATS AND TAKE THE
EVIDENCE TO THE LOGICAL
CONCLUSION.
SO MUCH COURAGE AT TIMES WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
IN A COUNTRY POLITICIZED AS OURS
NOW IS.
WE LEARNED TODAY, IT IS STILL
POSSIBLE, THANK GOD.
THIS AFTERNOON, THE JURY
ACQUITTED RITTENHOUSE ON ALL
CHARGES, THE JURY AFFIRMED WHAT
WAS OBVIOUS FROM THE BEGINNING,
HE ACTED IN SELF-DEFENSE.
IT WAS A WONDERFUL MOMENT.
ANYONE WHO BELIEVES IN IMPARTIAL
JUSTICE WAS VINDICATED.
THIS IS WHAT THE MOMENT LOOKED
LIKE.
>> WE THE JURY FIND THE
DEFENDANT KYLE H. RITTENHOUSE
NOT GUILTY.
AS TO THE SECOND COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, RICHARD McGUINNESS,
WE, THE JURY, FIND THE DEFENDANT
KYLE H. RITTENHOUSE, NOT GUILTY.
AS TO THE THIRD COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, UNKNOWN MALE, WE,
THE JURY, FIND THE DEFENDANT
KYLE H. RITTENHOUSE, NOT GUILTY.
THE FOURTH COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, ANTHONY HUBER, WE
THE JURY FIND THE DEFENDANT KYLE
H. RITTENHOUSE, NOT GUILTY.
AS TO THE FIFTH COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION GABE GROSSKREUTZ, WE
THE JURY FIND THE DEFENDANT KYLE
H. RITTENHOUSE, NOT GUILTY.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: REMARKABLE.
MONTHS OF LYING FROM THE MEDIA
IN THIS CASE IN THE END HAD NO
EFFECT WHATSOEVER FROM THE JURY.
PROPAGANDA DOESN'T ALWAYS WIN.
TODAY IT WAS SOUNDLY DEFEATED.
THANK GOD.
OUR DOCUMENTARY TEAM WAS IN
KENOSHA WHEN IT HAPPENED,
THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER A
TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS SERIES
ON THIS CASE.
AND THEY CAPTURED HIS FIRST
MOMENTS OUTSIDE OF THE COURT
TODAY AFTER BEING ACQUITTED.
>> IT'S THE STUFF THAT KEEPS YOU
UP AT NIGHT.
LIKE, ONCE YOU FINALLY DO GET TO
SLEEP, YOUR DREAMS ARE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED AND YOU'RE
BREAKING UP IN A DARK, COLD
SWEAT.
>> YOU HAD DREAMS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
IT'S QUITE SCARY, ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE THE DREAMS STILL FEEL
REAL AND THEY'RE NOT THE SAME AT
ALL.
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE IN
NARRATIVES THAT RUN THROUGH YOUR
HEAD IN THE DAY LIKE WHAT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED, LIKE, I'M ALIVE,
BUT WHAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED?
WHAT IF I WASN'T ALIVE.
OR WHAT IF I DID -- SO THOSE
TYPES OF DREAMS.
IT'S BAD, BUT ALMOST EVERY
OUTCOME IS EITHER ME GETTING
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR HURT OR
DEAD, THOSE ARE JUST THE DREAMS
I HAVE ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> THE DEFENDANT WILL RISE, FACE
THE JURY, AND WAIT FOR THE
VERDICT.
>> STATE OF WISCONSIN VERSUS
KYLE RITTENHOUSE.
THE FIRST COUNT, JOSEPH
ROSENBAUM.
WE, THE JURY, FIND THE DEFENDANT
KYLE H. RITTENHOUSE, NOT GUILTY.
AS TO THE SECOND COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, RICHARD McGUINESS,
WE, THE JURY, FIND THE DEFENDANT
KYLE H. RITTENHOUSE --
>> THE JURY REACHED THE CORRECT
VERDICT, SELF-DEFENSE IS NOT
ILLEGAL.
AND I BELIEVE THEY CAME TO THE
CORRECT VERDICT AND I'M GLAD
EVERYTHING WENT WELL.
IT'S BEEN A ROUGH JOURNEY, BUT
WE MADE IT THROUGH IT.
WE MADE IT THROUGH THE HARD
PART.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: YOU WATCH
THAT CLIP, YOU'RE REMINDED MAYBE
THE ONE PERSON IN AMERICA WHO
HASN'T WEIGHED IN ON THE TRIAL
IS KYLE RITTENHOUSE HIMSELF.
SO FOR MONTHS, CNN, KAMALA
HARRIS, AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DEFINE HIM.
THAT ENDS THIS MONDAY WHEN WE'LL
HAVE HIM ON THE SHOW MONDAY
NIGHT.
WE HOPE YOU WILL.
AS A LEGAL MATTER, THIS IS OVER.
KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS INNOCENT IN
A COURT OF LAW.
HE'S FREE TO RESUME HIS LIFE.
FOR THE AUTHORITARIANS AMONG US,
THIS IS A DISASTER, THEY CAN'T
LET IT GO.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND THE
RITTENHOUSE CASE IS A REFERENDUM
ON THE MOST BASIC RIGHT OF ALL,
THE ANCIENT RIGHT OF
SELF-DEFENSE.
IF KYLE RITTENHOUSE CAN SAVE HIS
OWN LIFE FROM THE MOB, THEN YOU
CAN TOO.
THAT DRIVES THEM INSANE -- SO
INSANE THAT THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TODAY,
JERRY NADLER OF NEW YORK IMPLIED
KYLE RITTENHOUSE MAY FACE
FEDERAL CHARGES.
THIS VERDICT, IN AEDLER WROTE,
JUSTIFIES FEDERAL REVIEW BY THE
DOJ.
SO JOE BIDEN'S JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INDICT KYLE
RITTENHOUSE NOW HE'S BEEN
ACQUITTED BY A JURY IN
WISCONSIN, IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
YOU HAVE TO BE DERANGED TO
CONSIDER THAT.
WHAT WOULD BE THE EFFECT ON THE
COUNTRY.
YOU NEVER KNOW WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
AT THE LEAST, THE CASE WILL BE
USED TO JUSTIFY TAKING YOUR GUNS
AWAY.
BET ON IT.
BUT, IF IT DOES GO TO THE FEDS,
IF KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS
PROSECUTED BY THE DOJ, THE CASE
WILL BE HANDLED BY KRISTEN
CLARK, THE BLACK NATIONALIST
THAT RUNS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DIVISION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE DIVISION THAT
DOES NOT PROTECT YOUR CIVIL
RIGHTS, IN FACT, TRYING TO TAKE
IT AWAY.
LAST YEAR, SHE WEIGHED IN ON THE
CASE AND ZEROED IN ON
RITTENHOUSE'S COLOR, LIKE HIS
RACE WAS SOME KIND OF CRIME.
SHE DESCRIBED HIM AS A, QUOTE,
ARMED WHITE MAN, KILLING
INNOCENT PROTESTERS AT, QUOTE,
POINT BLANK RANGE.
WHAT DOES HIS RACE HAVE TO DO
WITH ANYTHING?
WHAT DOES IT HAVE TO DO WITH
ANYTHING, OF COURSE, BUT IT'S
BEEN A FIXATION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FROM THE FIRST
MOMENT.
THEY'VE TRIED TO RACIALIZE.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TRYING TO DO
THAT.
JUST HOURS AFTER THE VERDICT, A
CONGRESSMAN RELEASED THIS
STATEMENT, QUOTE, IT IS
DISGUSTING AND DISTURBING THAT
SOMEONE WAS ABLE TO CARRY A
LOADED ASSAULT RIFLE INTO A
PROTEST AGAINST THE UNJUST
KILLING OF JACOB BLAKE, AN
UNARMED BLACK MAN.
END QUOTE.
SAVOR THAT.
THAT'S THE HEAD OF THE DEMOCRAT
KRALTIC CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN
ARM.
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT IS WRONG,
NOT JUST A LIE, BUT -- JACOB
BLAKE WAS NOT KILLED.
HE WAS ALSO NOT UNARMED.
HE WAS CARRYING A KNIFE, YOU
KNOW?
BECAUSE HE SAID HE WAS CARRYING
A KNIFE.
HE WAS TRYING TO KIDNAP A CHILD.
THAT'S WHEN THE POLICE SHOWED
UP.   WHEN HE GRABBED A KNIFE,
THEY SHOT HIM.
THAT'S NOT IN DISPUTE.
HE'S STILL ALIVE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
BECAUSE TO THESE PEOPLE, FACTS
DON'T MATTER, CLEARLY.
SEAN PATRICK MALONEY HAS NO
INTEREST IN WHAT HAPPENED.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID SHE WAS PROUD
OF JACOB BLAKE LAST YEAR, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE STICKING
WITH THAT TOO.
THEY ARE TRYING AND THEY HAVE
BEEN FROM THE BEGINNING TO MAKE
THIS CASE INTO A RACIAL DIVIDE,
TO FURTHER DIVIDE THE COUNTRY.
KAMALA HARRIS TODAY SAID THAT
THE OUTCOME OF THIS CASE, THE
JURY'S VERDICT, WAS PROOF THAT
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM IS NOT,
QUOTE, EQUITABLE, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
STATE OF NEW YORK SAID IT NEEDS
TO BE COMPLETELY TORN DOWN AND
REBUILT, OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM,
THAT WE'VE HAD FOR 250 YEARS,
THE BEST THING IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE TRIED ON
THE BASIS OF THE FACTS, NOT ON
THE BASIS OF WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE.
THEY'D LIKE TO CHANGE THAT.
ABC NEWS REPORTED THE SAME
THING.
THEY TOLD US, ABC NEWS, A NEWS
CORPORATION JUST TOLD US THAT,
IN FACT, JACOB BLAKE WAS KILLED
IN KENOSHA.
WATCH THIS.
>> WELL, IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT,
FIRST FOR THE COMMUNITY OF
KENOSHA, THIS CITY WAS
TRAUMATIZED BY THE POLICE
KILLING OF A BLACK MAN, JACOB
BLAKE.
>> THE POLICE KILLING OF A BLACK
MAN WHO IS, IN FACT, STILL
ALIVE.
SO, WHAT ARE THEY DOING WHEN
THEY TELL LIES LIKE THIS?
LIES THAT YOU CAN CHECK VERY
EASILY OR IF YOU HAVE A MEMORY
THAT EXTENDS TO LAST YEAR, YOU
RECALL VERY WELL.
WELL, THEY'RE INSITING PEOPLE,
OF COURSE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO WHIP PEOPLE
INTO A FRENZY ON THE BASIS OF
CLAIMS THAT ARE TOTALLY PROVABLY
UNTRUE.
WHAT KIND OF A FRENZY?
WELL CONSIDER THIS.
THIS IS FROM A SENIOR ADVISOR AT
THE D TRIPLE C, THE DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGN ARM.
HIS NAME IS DAJUAN ISSUING A
CALL FOR RIOTS.
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE, HE WROTE
IN THE WAKE OF THE VERDICT.
WHO IS HE?
HE SPENT A DECADE IN PRISON
AFTER HE SHOT TWO PEOPLE.
NOW HE WORKS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, IN CASE YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN WHOSE SIDE THEY'RE ON.
BUT YOU KNEW THAT.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR CONGRESSMAN
VAL DEMOCRATINGS, ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT, OFFERED THIS
ASSESSMENT, THE CORE OF THE FAR
RIGHT MOVEMENT IS THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO KILL YOU IF THEY WANT
TO.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL LINE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TONIGHT.
KEEP IN MIND, IF YOU WATCH THE
TRIAL, YOU KNOW THIS, KYLE
RITTENHOUSE WAS WALKING DOWN THE
STREET WHEN HE WAS CHARGED BY A
CONVICTED CHILD RAPIST AND
CHARGED BY A  NUMBER OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
HE SOUGHT NO CONFLICT.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY EVIDENCE HE
WAS THE AGGRESSOR IN ANY CASE.
HE WAS AGGRESSED AGAINST.
SO, JOE BIDEN ALSO WEIGHED IN ON
THIS.
HE GAVE TWO VERSIONS OF HIS
VIEWS ON IT.
FIRST HE SAID WE'RE GOING TO
RESPECT THE JURY'S VERDICT.
THEN WHEN HIS ADVISORS TOOK OVER
AND WROTE A NEW PRESS STATEMENT,
HE TOLD US HOW UPSET HE WAS BY
THE VERDICT.
AND THAT'S WHAT AIRED ON MSNBC
ALL DAY.
>> THE NEXT TIME THERE'S A -- A
PROTEST OF SOME SORT, AND IT MAY
GET POLITICIZED, THAT GUN
OWNERS, WITH A CERTAIN IDEOLOGY
MAY FEEL INCENTIVEIZED NOW, MAY
FEEL EVEN EMBOLDENED.
>> WHAT SOME MAY TAKE FROM THIS
VERDICT IS VIGILANTE JUSTICE
PREVAILED.
>> KNOWING THE HISTORY OF
VIGILANTE JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY ALL THE WAY BACK TO
TIMES OF ENSLAVEMENT, WHEN
PEOPLE WOULD BE DEPUTIZED TO GO
DOWN AND ENSLAVE PERSONS WHO RAN
AWAY, TO LYNCHING MOBS, THIS IS
2021.
>> THE CURRENT AND FUTURE KYLE
RITTENHOUSES OF THE WORLD THAT
THEY CAN ENGAGE IN WHITE
VIGILANTEISM AND BE LET OFF FOR
IT, BE DEFENDED AND PROTECTED
FOR PERPETUATING WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> WHITE VIGILANTEISM, WHITE
SUPREMACY, WHITE, WHITE.
ALL OVER MEDIA ALL DAY LONG,
EXPLICIT RACIAL ATTACKS.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THIS CASE?
AND IN WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY IS
THAT ALLOWED WHEN THE MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
LEVEL EXPLICIT RACIAL ATTACKS
AGAINST ONE OF THEIR COUNTRYMEN?
MOST OF US DIDN'T GROW UP IN A
COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE TALK LIKE
THIS.
THIS IS A REMINDER IN CASE
YOU'RE TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A YEAR, EVERYONE INVOLVE
IN THIS CASE IS THE SAME COLOR.
THE PEOPLE COUNSEL ON
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS
OFFERED THIS TAKE, WHICH WAS
VERY COMMON TODAY ON THE LEFT.
QUOTE, IT IS DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE A BLACK OR MUSLIM
DEFENDANT ENGAGE IN THE SAME
CONDUCT BEING FOUND NOT GUILTY.
REALLY?
WERE YOU HERE FOR THE O.J.
TRIAL?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
MSNBC, THE NETWORK BANNED FROM
THE COURTHOUSE FOR FOLLOWING
JURORS AROUND BROADCAST THIS
FROM THE RELATIVE OF JACOB
BLAKE.
>> YOU TELL US WHY HE GOT A FREE
RIDE.
THE BAIL MONEY WAS RAISED BY THE
PROUD BOYS, THE KU KLUX KLAN,
THE NAZIS, THE SKIN HEADS.
ARE THEY UP IN THIS COURTROOM?
DO WE KNOW THE HISTORY OF THIS
JUDGE?
TELL THESE PEOPLE IN KENOSHA FOR
MANY YEARS.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: IT'S REALLY,
REALLY DARK.
THE REST OF US SHOULD NOT ALLOW
THEM TO GET AWAY WITH
RACIALIZING THIS, ALLOWING THEM
TO GET AWAY OF ATTACKING PEOPLE
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR SKIN
COLOR.
THAT IS ALWAYS GONE, WE WOULD
NEVER ENGAGE IN THAT, NEVER
HAVE, NO ONE SHOULD DO THAT.
IT DIVIDES THE COUNTRY.
IT'S IMMORAL, FLAT OUT.
BUT SOMEHOW TO THE CRAZY LOGIC
THAT GOVERNING THEIR POSITIONS
AND DEEDS, THEY WIND UP
DEFENDING CHILD RAPISTS AND
DOMESTIC ABUSERS, ELEVATING THEM
TO SOME SORT OF HERO STATUS.
THE FORMER MAYOR OF NEW YORK
BILLDY BLAS YOU WROTE, ANTHONY
HUBER AND JOSEPH ROSENBAUM WERE
VICTIMS, THEY SHOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY.
MAYBE WE'LL GET A SMALL STATUE
OF ROSENBAUM.
THE ACLU, WHICH YOU WOULD THINK
WOULD BE IN FAVOR OF
SELF-DEFENSE SUGGESTED CROSSING
STATE LINES IS A CRIME.
STAY IN YOUR OWN STATE.
DESPITE HIS CONSCIOUS DECISION
TO TRAVEL ACROSS STATE LINES AND
INJURE ONE PERSON, TAKE THE
LIVES OF TWO PEOPLE PROTESTING
THE SHOOTING OF JACOB BLAKE BY
POLICE, HE WAS NOT HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR HIS ACTION.
INSANITY.
THE CONTINUOUS REFERENCES TO
CROSSING STATE LINES ARE NOT
INSIGNIFICANT.
THEY'RE MEANINGLESS.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO CROSS STATE
LINES IF YOU'RE AN AMERICAN
BECAUSE IT'S YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU CAN GO TO ALL 50 STATES.
WHY DO THEY BRING THAT TO EVERY
ANALYSIS OF THE CASE?
CROSSING STATE LINES.
THEY WANT TO USE IT TO CHANGE
GUN LAWS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU WATCH.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
WORST PEOPLE ARE SAYING, TUNE IN
TO JEB BUSH'S FORMER FLAK ON
MSNBC.
SHE TOLD US ANYONE WHO CROSSES
STATE LINES IS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST.
>> THE KYLE RITTENHOUSE
ACQUITTAL NOT GUILTY ON ALL
COUNTS DID NOT HAPPEN IN A
CULTURAL VACUUM.
THERE'S ALARMING CONTEXT TO THIS
MOMENT WE'RE CONSIDERING AND
TALKING ABOUT.
LAST WEEK, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY RELEASED THE
LATEST BULLETIN WARNING
AMERICANS, AGAIN, OF THE ONGOING
THREAT POSED BY DOMESTIC VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA FOR MANY, MANY MONTHS HAVE
BEEN PRIMING ITS AUDIENCE FOR
THIS MOMENT, FRAMING RITTENHOUSE
AS A HERO.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: SO, WHY ARE
WE INFLICTING TAPE LIKE THAT ON
YOU ON A DAY WHEN ALL OF US
SHOULD BE CELEBRATING.
WE'LL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE NONE OF THAT MADE ANY
DIFFERENCE TO THE JURY.
AND IF YOU'RE TOTALLY ABSORBED
IN AMERICAN MEDIA, YOU GET THE
IMPRESSION THAT AMERICAN MEDIA
ARE IN CHARGE OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND IT TURNS OUT, THEY'RE NOT.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T WATCH THAT
CRAP.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
THAT SAY.
THEY DON'T CARE AT ALL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF RATIONAL,
DECENT, THOUGHTFUL PEOPLE ON ALL
SIDES OF ALL RACES IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE STILL WILLING TO
THINK CLEARLY ABOUT WHAT IS
RIGHT, WHAT IS WRONG, WHAT IS
FACTUAL, WHAT IS FALSE, WHAT IS
JUST, AND WHAT IS NOT.
AND TODAY, THEY DID.
SO, THAT'S THE REAL LESSON
HERE.
IN THE FACE OF ALL OF THAT
PROPAGANDA, A GROUP OF JURORS IN
KENOSHA, WISCONSIN, WERE BRAVE
ENOUGH TO REACH THE RIGHT AND
OBVIOUS CON